streaming had already been gaming
popularity even before the pandemic but
the virus the local quarantine that took
place afterwards really began to
accelerate the trends that were already
happening one of the early indications
that we saw was in the first quarter of
this year from from January through
March people began to cancel their pay
TV services the cable and satellite
services and record rates the analyst
firm Nathanson Moffitt identified 1.8
million subscribers who had canceled in
the first three months of this year one
of the major reasons might logically be
the lack of professional sports you know
basketball baseball football has been a
lifeline for these paid cable services
it has been the critical retention tool
for cable and satellite it has been the
one reason to continue to pay for TV
service without sports linear TV really
is dying and they're probably not coming
back even when Sports comes back all of
the ambitious exciting content that you
want to see is all coming out on
streaming services there's really
nothing in the kind of linear TV world
that matters anymore as part of that
cable bundle and so I think the reality
is people just don't even think about
turning on the TV to watch a show with
20 minutes of ads where episodes are
still coming out week to week
it is literally becoming a thing of the
past in most people's heads and I think
that's why cord cutting hit record
levels now one of the clear
beneficiaries of that has been Netflix
Netflix is already the leader in
streaming by a wide margin
internationally when Netflix reported
its numbers in April for the first three
months of the year it reported an
astronomical fifteen point seven million
subscriber gain globally that has more
than double the forecasts for that
period another of the beneficiaries of
the pandemic has been Disney's Disney
Plus streaming service that service
launched in November it had a very fast
ramp because it had the benefit of all
of Disney's prominent brands at head
Pixar Animation and Lucasfilm star wars
films and it had Marvel theaters being
closed
when steam parks being closed this was
the lone bright light it is now
reporting fifty four point five million
subscribers in a short five months which
is a very rapid acceleration if filming
of TV and film production can't restart
in the fall by the time you get into
2021 you are gonna be running more on
catalog than ever before now that will
certainly advantage the companies with
the biggest catalogues and so if you
look at just the depths of what Netflix
is assembled it probably favors them
over others but you look even they are
gonna have an impact at some point
there's been a 13 percent draw in
national television advertising
according to researchers and that will
have a direct effect on what the
television networks the traditional
networks can afford to spend to create
programming and we may as a consequence
see more less expensive programming more
game shows or reality shows which are
less complicated to shoot don't require
multiple locations don't require complex
camera work or editing I think that we
will this what this too will accelerate
a trend that has already taken place
where the resources that are available
to networks to develop programming are
there further constraint the reality is
everyone in streaming is winning our
companies like Netflix and Amazon Prime
and Disney and Hulu winning sure but the
tide is coming in and lifting everybody
in in the sector and I think you know
the danger for the traditional
television world is the more time you
spend on streaming the more this becomes
part of your daily routine it's gonna be
much harder to go back my guess is the
court cutting that you saw in q1
especially with 20 plus million people
unemployed you're gonna see cord cutting
throughout the rest of 2020 at just
record rec levels that this industry has
never even thought imaginable I don't
see a day where the cable business has a
revival I think that these behaviors are
permanently changed